in our series a more perfect union we
aim to show that what unites us as
Americans is far greater than what
divides us today we introduce you to two
childhood friends who are turning
recycled bouquets into moments of joy in
Minnesota Adriana Diaz joined the duo as
they delivered much more than just
flowers Bloomington Minnesota is in full
bloom that's where you might call Karen
Wooldridge and Laura Hogan full time
flower girls hi Maxine an idea sprouted
between the longtime friends early last
year
take unsold flowers destined for the
dumpster repurpose and deliver them to
those who could use an extra visit
seniors the flowers deliver a special
feeling that inspires both song and
dance we started working on our kitchen
island and we were really proud of
delivering a dozen or two dozen flowers
then what happened what happened Laura
what we say now they rearranged nearly a
thousand bouquets a month with 150
volunteers working five days a week
maybe this is bluebirds and blooms named
after the Paris childhood youth troupe
the blue birds the flowers brighten 30
communities it kind of opens a
conversation that opens a door
mostly homes for seniors with memory
loss like the well Shire
[Music]
I'm not used to this valley Larson has
dementia some memories may have faded
but her daughter Karen Schwartz was in
the same Bluebird troop as Wooldridge
and Hogan and belly topped them all
music what did you think when they gave
you the flowers today I just was in
shock and I why why would they give me
flowers I think they just wanted you to
have something nice but believe me I
took them fast they're not getting them
there
when they deliver flowers to her she'll
call she'll describe him to me and give
me a flower and report every day
the flowers are also a reminder that
someone cares even if the memory of who
has gone says the center's director of
Life Enrichment Cheryl Hassan that was
pretty special I know they're confused
and sad and just to have such a simple
thing as a bouquet of flowers just
brightens their day families will come
in and they'll say oh we got you flowers
this is beautiful and it says thinking
of you so the resident can just say oh
somebody was thinking of me
so if you pluck off all the little guys
for Wooldridge the act of kindness
brings back fond memories of her father
who had Alzheimer's I know he would have
loved visits from these women he would
have called of girls coming in with a
bouquet of flowers it would have made
his day what do you think your father is
thinking of what you're doing right now
oh I even thought of that but he would
be so proud is that if we're difficult
doing this kind of work you're with
people who are struggling with memory
loss and you're with them every day
almost does it weigh on you it's happy
to us it's doing something good and
Tuesday a woman said to me you've made
my day and I just looked her and said
well you've made my day returning the
favor
with flowers for CBS this morning
Adriana Diaz Bloomington Minnesota
[Music]
everybody happy guys great idea no
simple and so big but it works so big
and in the town of Bloomington
appropriately at all yeah like that too